catalytic converter theft is the problem
really growing across the valley we
thank you for joining us at 11 I'm Brian
Loftus now the city of North Las Vegas
considering new ways to stop the crime
no one seems immune to it in fact a
local Boys and Girls Club even falling
victim that's where Sasha Loftus is
tonight live near Sahara and Jones
here's Sasha with more
Brian those who I spoke with here at the
Boys and Girls Club say they're glad to
hear something could be done about this
they say they spent way too much time
and money dealing with these cattle
could catalytic converter thefts
we just can't afford to keep doing it
Andy Bishop shares his frustration over
a rash of catalytic converter crime I
don't want it to happen anywhere but I
just really don't want it to happen here
as president of the Boys and Girls Club
of Southern Nevada he says their West
Valley location has had multiple units
stolen over the past year they know
they're stealing it from the Boys and
Girls Club that's that's the kind of
disturbing part for me in all they've
spent about 25 thousand dollars on
repairs and protection for their Vance
and they even started parking them
inside the gym at night
catalytic converter thefts continue to
be a huge problem across the Valley
Metro Police saw around 1900 cases in
2021 and 156 have been reported in North
Las Vegas so far this year a 28 jump and
since many of these parts don't have
identification numbers it's hard to tell
who they belong to the work that we do
is really meaningful to the kids and
families that we serve and anything to
delay that process is frustrating that's
why Andy says he'd like to see some
change to better track down those
responsible for taking so many in the
holiday season it's a it's a time for
giving not taking
of those 1900 catalytic converters
stolen in Metro's jurisdiction were told
only 98 arrests were made last year many
states have already passed laws trying
to curb these crimes the Nevada
legislature is set to hear at least one
bill related to catalytic converter
thefts coming up next year reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now